[Musica]
che cosa hanno in comune Biancaneve e i
sette nani
l'eurotunnel e la ricostruzione in
Australia dopo l'alluvione
Scusate ho solo 12 minuti per questo
Talk per cui non posso ascoltare le
vostre risposte e do io la risposta e mi
perdonerete se la morale arriva prima
della favola la risposta è il sistema
finanziario stiamo parlando di Amedeo
Giannini che ha creduto e finanziato
Walt Disney stiamo parlando di
risparmiatori che attraverso le borse
hanno finanziato quel collegamento che
oggi ci permette di prendere un
croissant a Parigi la mattina e poi la
sera andare a ballare in un club
londinese stiamo parlando di imprese di
assicurazione come lloyds che hanno
indirizzato più di una catastrofe
naturale e sul sistema finanziario che
poggiano l'economia moderna
attualmente questo sistema finanziario
sta vivendo una rivoluzione tecnologica
la crasi fra le parole Finanza e
tecnologia ha portato addirittura un
nuovo vocabolo fintech
adesso andiamo al supermercato e per
pagare ci facciamo riconoscere dai
sensori biometrici del cellulare o lo
avviciniamo al post oppure avviciniamo
lo smart lo SmartWatch
pagamenti a portata di mano a portata di
polso mentre prima per gestire i nostri
risparmi
attivare una polizza richiedere un
prestito dovevamo prepararci uscire di
casa spostarci e incontrare il nostro
operatore Adesso possiamo farlo
comodamente la mattina in pigiama della
scrivania della nostra casa
E questa rivoluzione digitale ha tanti
benefici perché si abbattono le barriere
e aumenta l'accessibilità ai prodotti
aumenta l'offerta di servizi
aumenta l'efficienza le relazioni
diventano più immediate i costi si
riducono i tempi si velocizzano
E tutto questo a sua volta favorisce
l'inclusione finanziaria di soggetti
vulnerabili
contribuisce a ridurre il gender Gap
aiuta a combattere l'usura
Ora stiamo diventando più o meno
digitali ma il nostro cervello è il
risultato di milioni di anni di
evoluzione durante i quali noi abbiamo
interagito con altri esseri umani in
presenza non con piattaforme digitali il
nostro cervello di fronte a un volto una
faccia ci mette meno di un secondo per
formulare un'impressione un giudizio
talvolta un pregiudizio e decidere se
possiamo fidarci o meno di quella
persona che c'è dietro quella faccia e
stabilire una relazione duratura nel
tempo
siamo biologicamente programmati per
interagire fisicamente con altre persone
e siamo diventati bravi a farlo come
dimostriamo incontrandoci Nei parchi
andando a discoteche concerti eventi
come il Ted qui oggi dove siamo a
scambiare idee
c'è un passaggio però dalla faccia
all'interfaccia e questo passaggio non è
neutro perché computer tecnologia
algoritmi non sono solo strumenti
neutrali influiscono sulle nostre
decisioni in un semplice gioco come il
gioco Carta forbice sasso il nostro
processo decisionale è diverso se
pensiamo di giocare con un computer
contro un computer o se pensiamo di
giocare contro un altro essere umano
computer algoritmi interfacce
influiscono sulle nostre decisioni
nessuno al casello del pedaggio
dell'autostrada chiacchiera e saluta e
risponde alla voce digitale che ha
sostituito il casellante no tranne mio
padre che invece continua puntualmente a
dire arrivederci a lei
ora questo passaggio dalla faccia
all'interfaccia È importante anche in
contesti economici vi faccio un esempio
il gioco dell'ultimatum un gioco molto
famoso per gli economisti dove c'è un
giocatore a che riceve una somma di
denaro immaginiamo 10 euro che può
dividere con un altro giocatore un
giocatore B se B non accetta neanche a
Porta a casa Niente noi Mettiamoci nei
panni dei giocatori B quelli che devono
avere i soldi le risorse finanziarie ora
Secondo la teoria classica
dovremmo accettare anche solo un euro No
perché un euro È meglio di zero
Secondo la teoria classica la realtà
invece è che se l'offerta è troppo bassa
ci innervosiamo ci offendiamo e non
l'accettiamo ci arrabbiamo tenetele tu
quei soldi le tue elemosine non le
voglio e rifiutiamo l'offerta perché la
riteniamo in equa e noi siamo avversi
all'iniquità
le persone però sono maggiormente
disposte ad accettare offerte iniquie se
queste offerte provengono da un computer
invece che da un essere umano Quindi
vedete influiscono sui nostri
comportamenti computer tecnologie
algoritmi in tutto questo conta anche in
Finanza
proiettiamoci a gennaio del 2020 gennaio
di tre anni fa proprio in questi giorni
che succedeva Juan veniva annunciato il
primo lockdown di massa della storia
quindi si mettevano in pausa Le nostre
relazioni sociali fisiche
Lo standard and pour 500 che il
principale indice azionario statunitense
un indice che riflette l'andamento delle
grandi imprese statunitensile 500 più
grandi crolla
c'è una rapida e in attesa di Scesa dei
prezzi Qual è l'istinto dell'investitore
in questa situazione è quello di vendere
in discriminatamente tutti i titoli ad
alto rischio è un fenomeno che prende il
nome flight to Quality decisione che poi
non sarebbe neanche tanto corretta
perché come vedete dopo poco l'indice
inizia a risalire Ma al di là di scelta
giusta o sbagliata al di là di questo
chiediamoci
in uno scenario di panico
quale sarebbe la reazione dell'utente Se
invece di incontrare il suo consulente
di lunga data il signor Claudio Rossi
incontrasse Mister consulbot il nuovo
Avatar digitale
Beh assumere che la reazione dell'utente
sarebbe la stessa nei due scenari
potrebbe essere una pericolosa
semplificazione del comportamento umano
e noi dobbiamo stare attenti alle
semplificazioni molto attenti perché ci
sono state tante crisi
economico-finanziarie e molte non siamo
riuscite riusciti a prevenirli
prevenirle neanche prevederle perché
perché al centro dei modelli C'è una
persona un soggetto che nella realtà non
esiste esiste solo sui libri ma non è
poi quello che incontriamo al
supermercato
e un soggetto che cento per cento
perfettamente razionale ma in senso
economico non il senso evolutivo quindi
un soggetto che usa solo la logica
che non si interessa delle relazioni
sociali che impermeabile alle emozioni
non è così le emozioni condizionano
tutte le nostre scelte per fortuna
perché se no saremmo dell'idioti sociali
Anche quelle finanziarie
le emozioni condizionano tutte le nostre
scelte ma le emozioni sono molto
difficili da studiare perché sono dei
processi neurobiologici neurofiolo
neurofisiologici che avvengono nel
nostro organismo molto spesso senza che
ne abbiamo contezza consapevolezza
per cui se qualcosa avviene
inconsapevolmente e l'influenza dei
fattori su questi meccanismi decisionali
su questi processi su queste emozioni è
parzialmente inconsapevole Come facciamo
a studiarla
c'è un filone di studi estremamente
recente la neuroeconomia che ha messo
insieme Nei laboratori delle università
più prestigiose quindi Harvard mixlone
princeton cult Cambridge
studiosi provenienti da discipline
diverse
neurofisiologia biologia gli economisti
ingegneria psicologia Sociologia E
questa collaborazione tra studiosi di
discipline diverse ha iniziato
gradualmente a svelare questi meccanismi
decisionali i processi emotivi che
guidano le nostre scelte
Quindi è possibile studiare qualcosa di
complesso come i meccanismi decisionali
e le emozioni con un mix di Metodologia
per cui la rilevazione del rilevamento
della frequenza cardiaca della
sudorazione
osservare i movimenti dello sguardo
tracciandolo con la tecnica della i
trekking
rilevamento delle espressioni facciali o
ancora rilevando la risposta del nostro
sistema endocrino
osservando molecole come l'ossitocina il
cortisolo il testosterone che sono
fondamentali quando parliamo di fiducia
interazioni sociali rischio che sono
tutte parole chiave momenti cruciali e
tipici della Finanza
ora al centro del sistema finanziario
anche il più evoluto dal punto di vista
tecnologico e digitale C'è comunque
l'essere umano le persone che
interagiscono sia con le facce che con
le interfacce
se misuriamo con esattezza e studiamo i
meccanismi decisionali e le emozioni che
sono legate a queste interazioni
possiamo cercare di ridurre il divario
che esiste tra interagire con una faccia
o con un interfaccia e studiare questi
meccanismi importanti perché un sistema
finanziario che non funziona vuol dire
niente film di Walt Disney vuol dire
distanze geografiche più lunghe come
quelle Tra Londra e Parigi vuol dire
meno progettualità meno risparmi meno
investimenti meno un uovo oggi per una
gallina domani
Ora vorrei che pensaste un attimo ad un
momento in cui vi siete accorti di
essere super felici ed entusiasti
molto probabilmente in quel momento
c'era qualcuno accanto a voi
sono sempre di più gli studi che
mostrano che c'è una relazione positiva
tra le interazioni il calore delle
connessioni sociali la qualità delle
relazioni
e il benessere mentale fisico spirituale
la felicità delle persone
in Finanza questa interazioni sono
cruciali perché sono le fondamenta del
sistema finanziario ma non solo sono il
lubrificante dei suoi delicati e
Preziosi ingranaggi
e se le relazioni non sono di qualità il
sistema finanziario si paralizza
al centro di tutto quindi ci sono le
relazioni che devono essere di qualità e
le relazioni sono di qualità
se riconoscono considerano e generano
emozioni Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]